we'll keep taking calls at 6 1 7 8 3 0
47 50 going next to the 9 1 0 area code
caller from 9 1 0 who's this today we're
doing right now we're here Todd we're
not on speakerphone are we okay let can
we get off speakerphone no speakerphone
ever the speakerphone is ruining the
call-in show and as soon as we're off
speakerphone I'd love to take a class
okay oh that's so much better Todd go
ahead yes sir um here's the thing man
and this is more of a statement than
anything
okay well I'm not released a memo right
and the reason why I say this because
the Republicans are known for doing
stupid stuff anyway it's a memo written
by Republicans it would be different if
it was memo written by Norwegians okay
there's an independent nonpartisan memo
released in memo because it's going to
be stupid anyway yeah and I agree with
you listen here's the thing Todd if you
are concerned with classified
information getting out there that
shouldn't which Donald Trump claims he's
concerned with Republicans claimed they
were concerned with when it came to
Hillary Clinton's handling of classified
information then make sure that you
redact what needs to be redacted and and
released the thing I agree but what
where I am having a problem with the
release the memo stuff Todd is that it's
becoming a refrain for people who just
want to take attention away from the
serious Robert Mulder Russian
investigation as if the two things are
necessarily related and they're not but
but see I say this right did we just put
Chelsea Manning in jail for six years
but is relief in the moment then put
them a new dev in jail
oh sure yeah awesome and gentlemen we're
gonna see the memo though Todd like I
said to the last caller I think we're
gonna see the memo relatively soon right
right but I'm just saying it's gonna be
stupid we are Noah stupid it's a memo
written by Republicans that wrote that
support a Republican president release
it it's gonna be stupid the reason why
Jeff Sessions recused himself ah because
with all this stuff going down he don't
want to be involved
that that would suggest that Jeff
Sessions acted with significant
foresight and and I've seen no evidence
that that's something Jeff Sessions
really does Todd thanks for the call I
appreciate it okay thank you god hey
love you work you guys keep it up
alright thank you so much